welcome back to fake guru today we have
another we have a follow-up on Siraj
revolt a very serious follow up guys I'm
just gonna be honest with you from the
outset this is gonna be a lot less of
the kitty gloves thing I was doing last
time look if you don't know I already
made a video about Siraj revolt in which
I admitted that I like the guy and I've
liked his videos I've enjoyed some of
his videos in the past if you don't know
he's a machine-learning guy try not to
be too critical I was trying to say look
this guy needs to change he's great
educator but he's got some serious
ethical sort of shortcomings when it
comes to citing people saying somebody
gave me a starter script and it's the
whole script is not attribution and then
just crediting with starter code at the
bottom of a second footnoted page from
your original video that you call watch
me build a training bot he wasn't citing
people he ran a course where he didn't
have a refund policy he was banning
people from the group there were all
these really pretty big glaring red
flags but I felt like okay let's maybe
give him the benefit of the doubt one
more time my kind of closing words were
this sucks
this guy definitely falls into the fake
guru category however I hope that he
changes but new developments guys just
came out that it gets it gets so much
worse it's so much worse because last
time if just to remind you the
plagiarism was really he would take
people's code call it starter code
obfuscate that he was taking people's
code he'd hide it into his github repo
he would clone his github repo in such a
way that the original author did not get
credit it was all this shady stuff but
there was nothing out right I mean it
was like like plagiarism in name only
maybe not like true plagiarism but now
guys we he actually he actually played
just flat-out plagiarized an academic
paper so here it is here's here's the
paper right here this was found by
Andrew Webb on Twitter where he compared
Suraj's paper which is over here to this
paper right here and this paper right
here it was written by a whole team of
machine learning experts
it's called continuous variable quantum
neural network it was written
by six people now Suraj's paper was
written by exactly one person and it was
called the neural qubit biologically
inspired quantum deep learning now it
turns out this paper which he said he
wrote because I recently published a
paper called a neural qubits he's saying
I wrote this paper these are my original
ideas he says this is something I wrote
alone and basically it's just the big
plagiarism fest so here's one of the
pages that he plagiarized everything on
the page was plagiarized now it's
important to note guys this is not a
matter of he even just took just the
page and just plopped it on his paper
which would be bad enough he did that
thing which people would do in high
school they would take the sparknotes
and they would change like every other
word to try to get it to pass as like
their own work that's what he did so
it's not even like you know kind of
honest plagiarism it's like it's like
the kind that you're trying to hide
something so a great example is right
here it says X problems and non
communitive observables in an Suraj's
paper he calls it X problems of human
cognition so he just changes stuff so
for example right here it says in the
end of his now famous 1960 article in
Rogers it says at the end of his now
famous 1960 article so you just changes
one word write another one well it has
been shown that real computation can be
directly applied to problems in
numerical analysis in scientific
community it is not clear if it reduces
the discrepancy so Roger says while it
has been shown that real computation can
be applied straight to numerical
analysis and scientific computing issues
it is not evident so it's not clear it's
not evident that is basically the
summation of Suraj's contribution to
science on this paper I mean it is it is
absolutely breathtaking this guy Andrew
M Webb is the guy who found it and he
ends up writing more about it he is
constantly showing where Suraj is
plagiarizing here's another example
Suraj is basically directly taking even
equation so like he takes this right
here this whole image and he puts it
over here I'll show you guys he puts it
right here boom boom same image I mean
it's just directly it's just directly
taken I mean it's just
just totally shameless so that's
basically throughout the whole thing
it's pretty pathetic if I'm gonna be
honest because what this actually was
passed as is a scientific contribution
of Suraj so this is one of Suraj is
scientific contributions to the
community my whole shtick is that you
don't need to be be a PhD in order to do
research in order to contribute to this
field and I think I live that because I
recently published a paper called a
neural qubit I mean I can't even explain
the irony of this that Suraj is trying
to live out an example the only thing
he's living out is that maybe you should
be suspicious of people without pedigree
or a background in the field who are
purely self-taught and seem to be coming
out of nowhere with all these papers
that sound eerily familiar just things
that are other people are doing I mean
this pretty much shatters Suraj's chance
of being well-respected in the community
plagiarism is not finally looked upon by
anyone and I think with good reason but
especially in the scientific community
if you pass something like that else and
this is what it's what is amazing to he
live streamed this moment this this
October 11 October 11th he's saying look
I'm living out my values of you don't
need an education she saying look this
is mine he's doubling down the neural
qubit it's my idea
October 13th all of a sudden the apology
comes out after getting caught out after
getting caught out I mean that's the
whole thing right is he goes I've seen
claims that my neural qubit paper was
partially plagiarized already I'm pissed
off because it's like no what's the
point of saying partly plagiarized when
you've changed clear to evident I mean
what's the point of that this is true
and I apologize I made the vid and paper
to align with my two vids a week
schedule I hope to inspire others to
research moving forward I'll slow down
and be more thoughtful about my output
now here's why that just is kind of
angers me the whole point of what he's
saying is look I was just in a big rush
and so I just did what you know what we
do when we're in a rush we try to fit a
deadline but it's not what people do
people don't plagiarize to just fit
deadlines that's not
that's not like a normal human behavior
that like oh we just all do it don't we
guys don't we I mean you don't it be
like
it'd be like saying hey I really wanted
to get my start up off the ground so
because I was in a rush and I needed
some cash flow I just robbed a store you
know I mean we get it guys and in the
future I'll try to slow down and be more
thoughtful about where I find my money
it's like whoa wait wait you stole money
that's that's not like a thing we do I
mean that's not just like a Oh oopsie
you know like guys we don't we all just
do this don't we all just steal other
people's papers and pass it off as I
mean this isn't even but like this isn't
for like a homework assignment this is
like saying like oh here's what I'm
adding for the scientific community and
it's just frustrating because again I
mean even though he says he apologizes
it feels like he's he immediately
explains it away as well I was under a
tight timeframe but a tight timeframe
doesn't explain this this is like this
is like an ethical problem I mean this
is this is a problem you don't respect
other people's work that says nothing to
do with a time frame I mean this stuff
really infuriates me and I like I can't
look at it for too long because I'm
gonna get angry but like he switches we
to I in the paper that's what maybe
makes me the most angry as he goes the
the team's like we did this and Siraj
who has nothing to do with the research
says I I did it I surah' I Sarat just
like it's just like the starter code I
Suraj check out the last video if you
don't know what I'm talking about
I Suraj I am doing this why is the color
glitching I'm sorry about the color
thing I know that's happening I can't
fix it I'm going from green to pink no
that's a huge I mean that's a huge
problem look at this look at this in the
face phase space picture we treat the
conjugate variable Suraj I treat the
conjugate very oh you can't see that I
treat the conjugate variables X and P on
an equal footing in the phase space
picture I don't know
that ends my sort of defense of Suraj I
mean in my last video I was like really
going about as soft as you can get just
because I was
I liked Suraj and I thought that even
though I was seeing a pattern of
behavior I thought that maybe it wasn't
what I thought it was
and it appears to be so yeah really
sketchy stuff the other thing that
really upsets me is directly after he
makes his apology and whatever he shouts
out the teams that he plagiarized from
as if he wants to as if he's so happy to
give them credit he goes shout out to
the zan do AI team he goes they they and
the people doing original work in AI are
the real heroes is that you don't need
to be be a PhD in order to do research
and I think I live that because I
recently published a paper called a
neural qubits my aim has to always been
to try and make their work more widely
known among the masses and I'll continue
to do so no you're not trying to make
their work more widely known you're
trying to make it known as your work
that's that's like so late it's so lame
especially when the paper was built
around trying to hide the fact I mean
I've already gone through this with you
guys
it wasn't like oops I just you know took
it it's like let me take it and try to
hide the fact by changing words around
and make sure no one catches me
plagiarizing and then when you get
caught you apologize and shout out the
team that you plagiarized from you lied
about who did it it's not oh oops I need
to give more exposure its oops I said it
was me and actually it wasn't me who did
this thing pretty serious stuff but
that's all for me I think this is the
last time I'm going to talk about it the
the only reason I felt it was necessary
is because I felt it was necessary to
correct the record on the last video
where the last video we kind of left an
incomplete picture of the full scope of
this problem so that completes our Suraj
revolt fake guru series I guess
[Music]
but never to the trust
[Music]
for the common
[Music]